Even if I say I believe, if it doesn't give me the strength to pass, it
's the same as not doing anything. But that's the only thing I can do.
Kobayashi-san,
if you're asking me to help you pass, then I can't do it.
Pudding, no matter how long you
wait, you can do whatever you want with me.  Puffs,
cream coffee jelly, gateau chocolat, maple
syrup pancakes,
all the sweets I can eat
[applause] [
music] I hit the
flame 30 times,
even my nails hit the barbs many times, and it
ended in pain.I was in
trouble.I
couldn't think of a way to kill him.
If you attack as hard as you can, the city will be destroyed, but if you don't, I won't be able to
defeat you. Your
attacks are a little annoying, but I have to protect the city, and it looks like it's going to
explode, so I'm being too strong.
Elena put up a barrier, so I made a
deal with Mr. Kobayashi.  That's all I did, so how many
people have I become friends with?
Now that I feel uncomfortable, I'm at home, in my
true form, and this world is all about me.